[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 117 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Mok mandal and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie wark Melanie how are
you doing today I'm great thanks for
joining me for yet another week and
still in the actual studio yeah you're
still actually in the studio though I
know you've been running around a bit we
have I think when I go favorite people
and you know I am super thrilled our
interview this week is with dr. Fei Fei
Lee who is the chief scientists of a IML
machine learning at Google cloud she's a
visionary in the space and it was
incredible to be able to have her come
on so I'm looking forward to that
interviewer sharing that with the public
yeah it was really great sitting there
and listening and understanding at least
about a quarter as always we start with
our cool things of the week and then we
end with a question and so for this week
the question is actually you know if you
want to learn about machine learning
what are some and we'll list a couple of
options for you to explore but before we
get into that let's talk about the cool
things of the week one of the cool
things of the week is that there's this
new nonprofit that was started called
partnerships on artificial intelligence
and Tara Lyons who's new as a founding
executive director of this group is
basically leading this group to help
ensure AI is applied in ways that
benefit people in society to quote her
she said we will have to work very hard
to make it so that the benefits of what
we are creating are broadly distributed
and that technologies like AI are
applied to solve Grand Challenges
instead of being wielded exclusively by
privileged and narrow special interests
what's interesting about this is that
this specific nonprofit was pulled
together by Apple Amazon deepmind us
Google Facebook Microsoft IBM and
they've got board members that have
representatives from universities
foundations and groups like the American
Civil Liberties Union so it's a really
interesting organization that's come
about and is pushing for AI X to kind of
throw back to our machine learning bias
and fairness discussion a few weeks back
so that's one cool thing nice I'm gonna
mention something that actually I think
I've been wanting for a really long time
so if you use cloud datastore fully
managed export and import with cloud
datastore is now generally available if
we've ever used this tool probably for a
long time you'll remember the old admin
tool that was existed with
Kandra but a bunch of jobs it wasn't the
best experience one could possibly have
had I'll put it that way no it was good
it did the job but this tool looks to be
a whole lot better you will have a new
API there's integration with I am and
previously like you were looking at much
longer time so doing backups these
backups should be happening a whole lot
faster as well so if you want to check
it out we'll have a link in the show
notes to show through how you can export
and import entities through the
documentation it looks like a much nicer
and easier process than what we
previously had so I'm super happy about
that yes there's also a blog post out
there on how color the company uses the
new variant transforms tool for
breakthrough clinical data science with
bigquery this is interesting from a
genomics perspective for those out there
who are in that space so color is a
health services company that offers
affordable and accessible genetic
testing and they wanted to be able to do
more heavy data mining on the data that
they have to better understand their
client DNA so variants is a popular task
in genomic analysis and it's basically
identifying a variant of a specific
genome from some reference genome so
bigquery was something that they went
with because apparently it's very mature
in terms of its ability to handle type
of datasets that they're working with
because it's fully managed data
warehouse and it has strong genomic data
import mechanism and the very transforms
is recently released tool that's
basically it's and it's an open-source
tool it's out on github and we'll have a
link but it's basically able to handle
massive amounts of genomic data directly
and load it into bigquery for you and it
works with datastore too as far as I
understand oh yeah we'll post that out
there for you guys nice lastly one of
our teammates Eric Schmidt not that Eric
Schmidt different Eric Schmidt developer
advocate Eric Schmidt exactly I feel I
feel very sorry for him for that reason
now in some ways it could probably a
plus two yeah Prison codes right just
prison maybe he gets into places maybe
he does Google Cloud and n-c-double-a
team up for a unique March Madness
competition hosted on Kegel I believe
that's basketball anyways yes and they
this is their fifth annual one that
they've done where you're building up
models to predict and I guess build out
your arch madness
so that was launched actually last week
and closed
March 15th in terms of submitting your
predictions and submitting your model
and there's $100,000 prize pool yes the
prize pool and to note that that is
split out over I think first place is
25,000 second place is 15 and third
place is 10,000 which actually when you
think about it doesn't really add up so
wonder where the rest of the money goes
but anyways it works fine it's something
like that yeah so yeah you should check
it out we'll put the link in there if
you are a big basketball fan and also
love data yeah awesome all right well
why don't we go chat with dr. Faye feely
so today's podcast we are excited to
have join us dr. Faye Faye Lee who is
our chief scientist of AI and ml for
Google cloud and she is the associate
professor in computer science department
at Stanford who's currently on
sabbatical so welcome thank you and you
know before we get started we know about
your background but we would like to
have you tell in your own words who you
are and what you do I guess I consider
myself and a technologist and researcher
foremost I've been a professor for most
of my professional career and before
taking the sabbatical I've been the
director of Stanford AI lab and here at
Google
I'm chief scientist of AI and machine
learning overseeing bringing AI
technology to the enterprise world
through Google cloud that's great and in
terms of doing the work that you're
doing at Google cloud what are some of
the things that a chief scientists do
you do it's an incredibly fascinating
world here you know cloud is the biggest
computing platform that humanity has
ever invented to deliver computing
service to people and businesses so on
this platform our goal is to really
democratize AI services and products to
as many businesses and as many people as
possible and so Google Cloud offers a
suite of products from api's to
customized models to you know more close
collaboration and partnership services
to really try to enable businesses to
solve their critical problem through
I solutions we also in the meantime
advanced AI technology because as you
get close to solving real-world problems
new challenges arise and that inspires
the development of new AI technology and
we work closely with google's AI
research and development teams
throughout the entire company to advance
AI as well nice and I know that there
was recent release of like Auto ml and
there's been the advancements with GPUs
and tensor flow what are some of the
things that you've seen and especially
from like applied AI that you think are
very relevant in terms of what's
important for businesses to be aware of
yeah so that's a great question I want
to first take Auto ml as an example
because that's a product that really
truly excites me it bears the meaning
and mission of democratizing AI
beautifully we see that more and more
business would like to use AI as a
service to improve their products and
much of the power comes in to making
predictions and doing smart analytics of
the data the business have but it used
to be you know still is true that AI is
a pretty technical field it's also young
enough that not every business has the
kind of AI talent that Stanford or
Google has so the barrier of entry is
pretty high so we've been thinking about
how to lower the barrier of entry for
businesses to use AI so let's take image
as an example if you are a real estate
company maybe you want to attack
different kind of houses or rooms if you
are a retail clothing company you want
to take an image and tax shoes or
different kind of shoes or clothings if
you are a non-profit tracking wild
animals you would like to take photos
and tag lepers versus giraffes so
there's a lot of needs for
kind of AI work well one way to solve
the problem is through what we call
api's these are pre-trained model that
Google engineers have built that work
fantastically and companies can just
upload their images and get to say a
label from the pictures using these API
models but there's one thing that API
doesn't do for you which is
customization the the API results come
from a pre trained model that has a
pre-designed set of labels it's a lot of
labels thousands of labels but it's
still pre-designed but if you truly
cares about just tracking wild animals
or cares about satellite imagery you are
now in the realm of the need for
customization and in fact lots and lots
of businesses and people need
customization and they don't have that
capacity to do it from data curation all
the way to creating the model so we saw
that as a important opportunity and
created this new product called Auto ml
starting from image understanding or
image tagging that it's really almost a
plug-and-play
that customers can give us their data
that they want to label and we viewed a
specific customized model for them to
use I'm not gonna get into the details
but the model is built on some of the
cutting-edge Google AI technology this
must be really exciting for you
especially considering I know you
started out researching around computer
vision and to see where it has gone from
from when you started to where we are
now and how it's being more democratized
as it's made more accessible and I know
you were one of the inventors of image
net which is this well-known competition
that was really pivotal in the
advancement of computer vision which
came to a close last year and one of the
questions I wanted to ask you is just
sort of a sideline is how do you feel
seeing something that you built that had
helped advance a space that matters so
to you how do you feel now that it's
closed what does that mean to you so
first of all I think image that is
generally a group effort so many of my
colleague students are part of the core
creation team of image net and as a team
we are very proud we are proud that
image that has made a contribution
computer vision it is one of the driving
forces of what we see as the deep
learning revolution and closing down the
competition in the academic world is
really just the beginning of a new
chapter first of all cargo is now
hosting image net so the democratization
of image net data and this competition
itself lives on and it's reaching to
more developers it's also a sign of the
progress scientific discovery and
innovation is always built upon the
continuous renewal of ideas and image
net served a important historical
purpose when we decided to finish the
academic competition we recognized the
field is ready to embrace new ideas so
that's where we are with computer vision
and machine learning for those people
who aren't as familiar with say image
net can you explain a little bit about
what that is and also the transition
that it's gone through you said it's
gone into K go now so image net was a
project my students collaborator and I
did start in 2007 the end product by
2009 is a gigantic image data set of 15
million images labeled over 22,000
categories of objects and real world
objects and things and concepts and
publicly released to the world of AI
research and education it was the goal
of making image net was to reboot
machine learning research and rethink
the relationship between algorithm and
data it was built at the time that data
was not as recognized the key ingredient
of
AI systems image that's contribution I
think part of it is because of that it
enabled the family of algorithms called
neural network to show its potential and
because of that effort we think it was
important to encourage the academic and
research community to benchmark their
algorithms on the image net so we
created the image net competition start
in 2009 actually starting 2010 and that
competition served as a good platform
for international teams to benchmark the
progress we're making in computer vision
and the transition 2017 is that we
recognize just as I said before we've
come a long way the problem that image
net set out to duke object
classification and detection is I
wouldn't call largely soft but is made
so much progress that we need to create
a space for new problems and new ideas
inspire new things that new ways to
solve these types of problems different
problems exactly that's why we
transitioned it from an academic
competition to a kegel data set so in
terms of AI I've seen you talk about how
you like to emphasize that it's not
artificial why the emphasis that it's
not artificial and is this related to
also in reaction to AI hype do you have
any thoughts around that that you'd want
to share yes I now tend to say that I
share with my students and colleagues
that the field of AI is nothing but
artificial and what I really mean is
that this is a deeply deeply human
pursuit because AI as a technology is
going to influence and impact our human
lives and human society in very profound
ways and as technologists I think it's
really important to recognize that
humanity has never created a technology
that resemble ourselves as much as AI
does and of course part of ourselves is
being able to function with the level of
logical
in computation but part of being human
is also recognizing the the social
relationships the emotion that the
wanting to do good and all that
and since AI as a technology is so
powerful and impacting so many different
sectors of the world we want to
recognize its human impact and also
prepare ourselves to a iess human impact
so off of that human impact and also off
of what you're saying about image net
and trying to look into the next phase
of what research would look like I know
you've also talked about sort of the new
goalposts being around natural
conversation collaboration emotional
perception what do you think in terms of
where things are going and what types of
benchmarks are needed for those types of
goals yeah that's a good question I
think that if you look at the complexity
and the intricacy of human intelligence
being able to classify or group concepts
is only one of them that's what mostly
what image that did but whether it's our
visual ability or our navigation ability
or our natural language communication
ability or comprehension reasoning
emotion humans are really complex so I
think in order to think about the next
step of AI is really important to go
beyond the simple tasks that we are
starting to excel at but to recognize
the the complexity of intelligence there
are already some interesting budding
research Google and many other groups
are looking deeply at things like for
example natural language dialogue for me
that's a very interesting area where you
go beyond just labeling parts of
sentences to actually enabling a machine
human dialogue in meaningful ways for
our vision starting to tell the story of
a picture starting to reason and the
picture starting to understand the
events the human activities the object
functions and all this would be the next
step and take what we've excelled at and
do what you've been talking about
so democratizing it and making it
accessible for people right so your
research one of the areas that you've
been focused on lately is more in the
health sector can you tell us a little
bit more about what are some of the
things that you're exploring in that
space right so you're referring to some
of my collaborations with Stanford
School of Medicine and also Stanford
Children's Hospital and adult hospital
so a few years ago we thought deeply
about AI transformation and one of the
most exciting transformation that
everybody hears about is self-driving
cars and this is the result of advances
from sensing technology to perception
technology to machine learning
technology and all that and then we
recognize that there's actually a
parallel opportunity in healthcare that
has more analogy to self-driving car
than most people recognize it's really
about the space of care is that how do
we enable care in a more effective way
for example in hospitals there's a lot
of things going on and work could be
more efficient errors should be avoided
patients can be monitored further or in
Elder homes can we enable more
intelligent ambient sensing and machine
learning to help families and and
clinicians to take care of our elders
and all that and we start to recognize
wow this is the kind of technology
that's needed in these potential
services is very similar to self-driving
cars uses smart sensors to gather
information from the environment and
then back and uses computer vision and
machine learning techniques to recognize
activities and to make decisions so we
started to collaborate with Stanford
Hospital and also a senior home facility
in San Francisco to explore how we can
use AI to help avoid healthcare workflow
errors or to help aging seniors
especially early detection of the
and all that and a specific example is a
project we're doing with Lucile Packard
Hospital at Stanford where we put smart
sensors or depth sensors in the hospital
unit to help doctors and nurses monitor
their hand hiding practice it turned out
the lack of hand hygiene or
hospital-acquired infection is one of
the leading killers of our patients in
hospitals it kills more people than car
accidents per year and how do we
continuously monitor the behavior of
proper hand hygiene practice is actually
a very difficult task and it's expensive
to deploy people to watch people and
that is very sparse it introduces bias
so we thought well the same kind of
depth sensor self-driving car uses to
watch the pedestrians and the cars on
the road could be actually put into the
hospitals so we install these smart
sensors that are also privacy-preserving
and use computer vision technology in
the backend to be able to continuously
monitor and observe hand hygiene
practice in the hospital unit and that
was one of the first kind ever done in
that way and we're very excited to see
some initial results showing that a
automatic observing system using AI does
as good even better actually than human
observers but it doesn't get tired it's
all biased and all that that would be
great and and this was a recent
implementation so the results haven't
come back - we actually it's in
submission to a publication I'd love to
take a slightly different tack here I
mean this worker sounds fantastic but
you've been in the AI and machine
learning industry for a really long time
and you've watched it grow and you were
talking a bit about barriers to entry
and like the speed at which is
progressing if people are coming in you
the machine learning and AI now and
they're interested in getting involved
where should they go what should they do
what path do you think they should take
yeah good question um I get that a lot
as a professor so I think it depends on
what you're interested in if you are
interested in machine learning as a
research then I think it's important to
get involved in the research projects
that I assume that's when you have
already some technical background if
you're interested in machine learning
implementation and software engineering
there's already a lot of online courses
and you know Google's tensorflow
and the tensorflow community has a lot
of materials that can help to get your
hands on to the coding and software
engineering of the site if you're
interested in using machine learning as
a way to create interesting startups and
entrepreneur upper to nough T's start
thinking about the pain points of
different businesses and products and
and find areas where using smart data
analytics or machine learning techniques
can help solve a pain point but machine
learning and AI is not just technical
that goes back to my original point
there is actually a lot of related areas
machine learning and policy right or AI
and education AI for sustainability AI
for economics there there's a lot of now
new areas that are at the cross section
of AI technology and human impact so a
lot of people even without technical
background can get involved and
contribute you know I know that you get
asked a lot about the AI sort of one of
the bigger challenges and you spearhead
efforts around diversity inclusion and
you have this wonderful organization AI
for all can you tell us a little bit
about that and what it does yes so AI is
a field that largely stemmed from
computer science and I think it's pretty
obvious by now that the general field of
computer science and AI has a critical
issue of lack of diversity we lack women
we lack under
presented minority all the publicly
released data whether it's Silicon
Valley companies or academia we're
seeing a very small percentage of women
and even smaller percentage of
underrepresented minority in this field
and I think that is a pity because
involving more diversity would make our
field better and we talked about several
reasons one is for economic and labor
reason we need more and more CSA I
talents and we need to tap into all
walks of life it's also an innovation
creativity reason that when diverse
group of people coming together
solutions and ideas are more innovative
and it's also a fairness and justice
reason we want a technology to resemble
or or to represent the values of our
collective society we want all walks of
life to be involved in developing and
creating it for these three reasons at
Stanford about four years ago we started
this program to encourage diversity
group of high school students to
participate in the study and early
hands-on research of AI and we created
this program because Stanford AI lab
outreach summer and as Stanford we were
focusing on high school girls around
tenth grade and we bring them on campus
for two to three weeks in the summer and
they study AI perform also they study AI
and its human mission and human centered
impact and that has been very luckily
successful so we decided in 2017 to
expand it to a national nonprofit
organization we call it AI for all to
really replicate the the Stanford model
and create summer camps nationwide and
so we started with Berkeley last year
where they reached out to low-income
families and students
and I'm focusing on robotics 2017 were
expanding to Princeton to
underrepresented racial minority
students to study am policy and we are
expanding to CMU this year as well
to reach out to rural population and so
so we're expanding to six different
sites 2018 and we'll continue this
effort and we plan to include in our
show nuts two ways for people to link in
and and finance how to get involved I
want to make sure is there anything else
that you wanted to share or talk about
from AI from the research from
recommendations for people to think
about how they get involved how they can
get into the space yeah is incredibly
exciting like I guess I'm biased but
being a AI technologist and and also
educator for 20 years I think seeing
this field has grown from a niche
academic field to become one of the
biggest drivers of the fourth Industrial
Revolution is really extremely exciting
and rewarding and in this process I
think we are just at the beginning even
though we hear a lot about AI and its
progress so far but we really are just
seeing the beginning of the power of
this technology so I would love to see
more people getting involved and
different parts of the world
technologies technologists humanists
policymakers social scientists you know
law makers all come together and have
deeper and multi way dialogue and to
design this technology and also guide
the impact of this technology great
thank you thank you yeah thank you so
much thank you again dr. favourably we
are really grateful that you were able
to come on and talk to us about your
work what your research is what your
experience was how he felt about
imagenet all of it was wonderful and if
anything there were so many other
questions we still wanted to ask we were
limited on time so we worked with what
we had
yep but you're welcome back any time
definitely definitely so why don't we
move on to our question of the week and
I'm gonna ask you Melanie sure so I'm
interested in AI and ml in theory and I
would like to learn more where can I go
you mean I haven't beat it over your
head so there's a couple of resources
and we'll definitely add those in the
show notes and I'll probably come up
with some more when we post this but one
in particular that comes to mind is that
most people will talk about and ruing
famously has a Coursera course that's
out there that many will go to on a
regular basis when they are initially
starting out I've done half of that yeah
yeah sweet good job
maybe you'll get to the other half at
this point maybe if sei is also a group
out there that has some wonderful
content especially in terms of deep
learning and just helping to really
break down the basics around some of the
math and the machine learning in general
Google just launched a course on
Coursera and saying how Google does
machine learning so we will also include
that in our show notes but there's
definitely a number of resources these
are some key ones that come to mind and
yeah we'll make sure we share what we
have nice it looks like enrollment for
the Google one starts on March 12th good
point
all right well I think that's it for
this week and anything coming up for you
I don't think you've talked about
anything that you haven't GDC it's og DC
all the time that's all you do yeah it's
all I do yep so come say hello I'll be
at the booth I won't be at the developer
day but there's a Google developer day
that's gonna talk about a bunch of
different Google products on the monday
but i'll be at the booth various times
from wednesday to friday we're
sponsoring winning games international
so be at that party as well that's
probably about it that from the moment
i'm sure i'll have some more stuff
coming up awesome
well a happy International Women's Day a
day early since we'll be releasing this
on the 7th and I hope everybody out
there has a good one yes really I think
that's it for us for this week for this
week so yeah Melanie thank you for
joining me for yet another week on the
podcast thanks mark thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]
[Music]